it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story the job that keeps on
paying Sky News can tonight reveal how
Boris Johnson made 85 of all the outside
earnings paid two MPS this year
Prince Harry will take the stand in a
phone hacking trial which starts days
after his father's coronation
BBC presenter Gary lineker insists he
will continue to give a voice to the
voiceless after criticizing the new
migrant law
Plus
it was a death that didn't have to take
place
um my brother wouldn't have had to
suffer like he did
the catalog of failings which allowed a
prisoner to murder this man hours after
his release
a Nordstrom whodunit the Ukrainian
billionaire being investigated for
blowing up the gas pipeline as Kiev
denies involvement
and the game-changing weight loss drug
made popular on Tick Tock soon to be
available on the NHS
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening since Boris
Johnson walked out of Downey Street six
months ago he's made interventions from
the back benches on brexit and trading
Arrangements in Northern Ireland spoken
out on the lead to send fighter jets to
Ukraine and even advocated for his
father to be knighted but he's also been
making huge amounts of money nearly five
million pounds Sky News can now reveal
that the former prime minister pocketed
85 percent of the outside earnings
generated by 650 MPS our Deputy
political editor Sam coats has our
latest edition of the Westminster
accounts the most famous face in British
politics this week's six months since
Boris Johnson was forced to leave number
10. in resignation he promised the
nation there were good times ahead even
if things can sometimes seem dark now
our future together is golden for him it
certainly has been here are the MPS who
have declared the most in outside
earnings so far in this Parliament and
at the top it's not even close nearly
five million pounds in earnings for
Boris Johnson almost all of that earned
in the six short months since he
departed Downing Street
and 22 million pounds now that's the
total amount of money all 650 MPS have
declared on top of their 84 000 pounds a
year salary since the last election in
December 2019. and here are the MPS that
have registered the most in outside
income so far in 2023 so we've got the
data for just under two months of
earnings now understandably many of
these numbers are quite small but one
man clearly is having a very good year
financially at least the former prime
minister has registered over 3.7 million
pounds in extra income just since the
turn of the year he's been paid over 500
000 pounds by publisher harpercollins
for a book that's yet to be published a
nearly two and a half million pounds
from an agency which the former prime
minister describes as an advance for
speaking engagements now the sheer scale
of Boris Johnson's earnings are really
rather extraordinary so look at this 4.4
million pounds is the total sum of
outside earnings made by all 650 MPS so
far in 2023 and of that figure Boris
Johnson alone has earned 85 of the cash
a highly paid speaking gigs have spanned
Singapore New York and Mumbai and now
Westminster not Parliament there's a
conference just down the road Boris
Johnson giving his first public reaction
to Richie's next brexit deal what just
happens to be a very lucrative platform
Boris Johnson how much are they paying
you to pronounce at the brand Finance
conference why aren't you doing this in
Parliament
Uxbridge in West London is where Boris
Johnson has made his political home this
is not a safe seat some constituents far
from Happy do you think he should stand
again and if you if he did would you
vote for him
um no I don't think I'd vote for him
again
um he's making a lot of money like you
say doing other things so yeah step down
I'm okay with that but I wanted him to
focus more on his constituency I'm here
working six days a week but I never see
him being slung out of office by his own
party doesn't appear to have dented
Boris Johnson's earning power but is
this the golden future he dreamed of
and Sam joins me now from Westminster so
six months later Sam nearly five million
pounds earned but Ross Johnson hasn't
broken any rules so why does this matter
that's right right Anna absolutely true
that the Boris Johnson has not broken
any rules everything has been properly
declared and registered in the correct
manner as as far as we can possibly tell
but what's going on here anna is that
Boris Johnson is doing what he's done so
many times before in his career which is
to push the boundaries of the rules as
far as they can possibly go and just as
the previous occasions by doing that he
has provoked a strong reaction from a
lot of people now this matters because
Boris Johnson even though he was a
talismanic figure what he does is the
most famous politician in the country
rubs off on everybody else who works in
the building that I'm standing in front
of and this is also likely to restart
the conversation about whether it should
be MPS that decide exactly what the
rules are that they have to work under
because it is an irony and I will put it
no more strongly than that that the last
person to try and curb the second jobs
rules was Boris Johnson here was his
letter from November 2021 that was in
response to another Scandal involving
Owen Patterson then he said that
Parliament should consider imposing
reasonable limits and what MPS should be
able to do he ended up not being able to
imp Implement that because there was a
backlash from his own MPS he is now the
biggest beneficiary of that failure to
change the rules
Sam in Westminster thank you and you can
find out more about the Westminster
accounts a joint project between Sky
News and tortoise media and use our
special online tool by visiting
skynews.com or use the Sky News app
Prince Harry could take the stand in a
phone hacking trial just days after his
father's coronation after a high court
judge ruled that he should give evidence
he will be the most high profile
claimant in the case against the mirror
group with his legal team arguing that
more than 140 articles published over a
14-year period from 1996 included
information allegedly obtained using
unlawful means a warning that our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock's report
does contain flashing images from the
start
[Applause]
Prince Harry's hatred of the British
tabloid press is no secret and now he
has them in his sights heading to court
as star witness in a long-running
litigation he claims the tabloids tapped
his landline and hacked his phone for
headlines experts say his case against
mirror group newspapers will be seismic
this will be a full contested trial of a
claim brought by a senior member of the
royal family against the British press
it will involve him being cross-examined
in the witness box so the potential for
disaster is immense I mean it's just
huge
Prince Harry has a handful of cases
against British newspapers this one
adjoined action with other well-known
names but none as high profile as Harry
he says 148 stories were written about
him using information illegally obtained
his refusal to settle applauded by
privacy campaigners one thing this trial
will do whichever way it goes is the
judge will make a determination of who's
telling the truth and who did what when
and as the campaign to expose this
activity to the extent it went on that's
what we want we want the truth to come
out
the trial starts just three days after
the king's coronation it's the
post-party publicity the palace would
dread coming here to the Royal courts of
Justice would be an unprecedented move
by Harry a member of the British royal
family taking on the tabloids it is a
hugely risky decision
but it's one that shows how far Harry
will take his fight against the British
press Laura bundock Sky News at the high
court
well turning now to the government plan
to stem the flow of migrants arriving on
British Shores in small boats the day
began with the Home Secretary touring
the new Studios to defend her policy but
offering no new detail on how migrants
would be detained before deportation
tonight she's being urged to apologize
to civil servants after an email sent in
her name accused them of blocking
efforts to stop Channel Crossings Ali
foreskin has this report
immigration matters a long way from the
Kent Coast we need immigration for some
sort of sectors in our community yeah
but the big family members over and just
getting bigger and bigger and bigger in
marginal Northern seats like dewsbury
people you know illegally you know all
legal coming over
places that will become an election
Battleground where people are watching
the government's bold plan to stop the
boats we are rolling out new detention
spaces to support when the detention
pressures I'm not going to give precise
dates because uh we will have uh you
know we've got uh logistical uh
challenges that we're always overcoming
Logistics are one thing but is this bill
even legal look at this I'm unable to
make a statement that in my view this
bill is compatible with the European
convention on human rights that's very
unusual do you think this is going to
end up in court it will certainly end up
in the courts because individuals will
challenge what the government does this
bill obviously will take a few months to
go through Parliament and perhaps the
government hopes that this will be in
force by the summer then there will be
challenges and they could take months
even years to go through the court the
government hopes that simply publishing
this bill and talking tough will begin
to deter migrants from coming here will
you break the Lord to stop the boat but
the Prime Minister May well relish a
battle in the courts
and with the labor party he wanted to in
his words scrap the
voted against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
all they offer is the same old gimmicks
and empty promises I don't agree with
the home sector on very much but when
she says that the Tories are all talk
and no action she's spot-on isn't she
the government's weak spot is the
workability of this plan but immigration
policy is election material and they
sense a weakness in labor behind the
scenes number 10 are pretty pleased with
how the last few days have gone
he's a PM Keen to be seen in control
earlier marking International women's
day as he tries to tackle immigration
in the end success may be more about the
politics than the policy Ali Fortescue
Sky News Westminster
here's the face of football on the BBC
who's never been shy about his views and
despite what's been described as a Frank
conversation with his boss the
corporations director General
caroliniker has insisted he would
continue to speak up for those who have
no voice he was responding to critics
after describing the government's
migrants policy as Beyond awful Ashley
reports
Gary lineker says he's using his voice
for the voiceless but as the BBC
presenter is fast finding out that comes
with risk he's criticized the
government's new Asylum plan as Beyond
awful writing on Twitter this is just an
immeasurably cruel policy directed at
the most vulnerable people in language
that is not dissimilar to that use by
Germany in the 30s a view Downing Street
has slammed the language that he uses I
think that is inflammatory and wrong you
shouldn't throw around comparisons with
the Nazis and 1930s Germany he should
choose his language carefully just as
politicians should do and as a BBC
employee where the golden rule is
impartiality the stakes are high but the
former footballer has long defended
those who used to make the journey to
Britain I just thought how can we not
have a degree of empathy towards these
poor souls you know they're fleeing like
war-torn countries or oppression or
whatever it is
do you think they want to leave their
homes of course they don't they're
forced out it's why he's previously
opened his home to refugees this letter
from one man said he'd made him feel
like another member of his family he
decided to start hosting three years ago
he's not just empty hot air he's a man
who lives what he says who walks the
walk and for us that's incredibly
important we hope it encourages people
to host we also hope it helps people to
think well of refugees not to LEAP to
judgment to know that people who are
fleeing need help the BBC says its
employees are aware of their
responsibilities on social media but how
far is one of the corporation's most
high-profile broadcasters willing to
push it ashnaharinag Sky News
he didn't have to die those the words of
a grieving sister today as she accused
Scottish authorities of a catalog of
failings over her brother's murder Alan
Gettys was stabbed 40 times hours after
a violent prisoner was released from
prison a report released tomorrow will
conclude that Stuart Quinn who had a
history of psychotic episodes was
offered no accommodation or care package
conagulus reports are you daddy's boy
Lucas Allen Geddes adored his son Lucas
a popular family man but he was brutally
murdered at the hands of Stuart Quinn a
violent serial criminal with a history
of psychotic outbursts
someone who'd been released from prison
here in the northeast of Scotland just
hours before he stabbed Alan 40 times
came out in court that he was he had
been shouting for his family that his
family would would help
and and that that that brings in my ears
and it breaks my heart Stuart Quinn's
released from prison that day it was
both unexpected and unplanned and it led
to him having a distressed state of mind
now a report sheds light on how the
authorities handled that release and it
paints a very Bleak picture it says that
he posed a risk of violence there was no
accommodation or care package put in
place and it concludes that that is
likely to have impacted the outcome
this report is a catalog of feelings
it's almost like we're enabling them to
go out there and do it because nobody's
nobody's doing anything about it
nobody's making a decision therefore
someone is either going to be hurt badly
or killed and your brother well my
brother was the one that was killed yes
this report examines the Killer's
interactions with NHS mental health
teams in the 18 months leading up to the
murder it states aspects of that care
including how risks were assessed and
managed which have acted on might have
mitigated the risk of violence
systematic failures right across the
system it's quite clear that Stuart
Quinn should never have just been
released back into into society there
were gaps in the system to prepare
inmates for reintegration the process
suspended due to operational pressures
three months before Quinn was freed
authorities say an overhaul is coming
I'm angry now I'm angry that um
my brother would still have been here
that um
it it was a it you know it was a it was
a a death that didn't have to take place
um my brother wouldn't have had to
suffer like he did
the officials involved have promised to
learn lessons Conor Gillis Sky News
Sky News understands that Iran has
allegedly been secretly supplying large
quantities of ammunition To Russia for
the war in Ukraine a security source
told us that two Russian flagged cargo
ships departed an Iranian port in
January Bound for Russia with more
shipments expected our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes has this
exclusive report
Russia is burning through ammunition in
Ukraine it means Russian industry is
under pressure to produce more
now claims have emerged that Moscow is
also receiving help from a close Ally
a source alleges that two ships
transported a large amount of ammunition
in January from Iran to Russia paid for
in cash
Security Source told me the two ships
are thought to have been carrying up to
a hundred million bullets and around 300
000 shells of varying sizes for
different weapons like machine guns
grenade launchers mortars it's not been
possible independently to verify the
volume and one expert said it did sound
quite high but Iran is certainly
suspected of supplying an amount of
ammunition To Russia to help replenish
stockpiles that are thought to be
running low
Sky News is data and forensics unit
looked into the movement of the two
Russian ships that were named by the
source as the Musa Jalil and the bege
on the 9th of January marine traffic
data show them in the Iranian Port of
amiribad on the Caspian Sea
this satellite image is taken the
following day
one of the ships the massage allele seen
here is likely turning to leave the port
later the other ship beg a and now Mr
Jalil appear to have left and are
traveling north towards the Russian
Coast
by the 27th of January they've reached
the Russian Port of Astra Khan the
vessels can be seen here and here in
this satellite image taken on the 2nd of
February
Sky News hasn't been able independently
to verify what they were carrying
Ukraine's ambassador to the UK says he's
not surprised about the ammunition
claims given that Iran is already
supplying Russia with deadly drones
this is a sort of a collision of of the
weak Nations trying to you know to
consolidate their last efforts to
withstand the pressure of much bigger
Western support which Ukraine is is
quite happy to have
but President Vladimir Putin is still
talking tough as his military fights on
asked about the ammunition claims
Russia's defense Ministry and Iran's
foreign Ministry have yet to give a
response Deborah Hayne Sky News
now Russia was the obvious suspect when
the Nordstrom gas pipeline was targeted
in a sophisticated attack last September
Now new information is emerging about
the investigation into who was
responsible with intelligence suggesting
the operation could have been sanctioned
by a Ukrainian billionaire involving a
yacht and divers Kiev has denied
involvement and Western allies have
urged caution warning that
investigations are ongoing
to Washington now where the head of the
FBI has warned the Chinese government
could use tick tock to control the data
of millions of American users addressing
a senate hearing FBI director
Christopher Wray said the chinese-owned
video app screams of security concerns
they can collect our data manipulate
information poison the mines and feed
garbage into the minds of millions of
people and so forth given the threat I
imagine this is the reason why Tick Tock
is no longer allowed on federal devices
pretty soon no federal devices can have
tick tock on it correct
well certainly at the FBI uh no uh if
Tick Tock never has been and nor will it
be approved and I think it's my
understanding that that's about to be in
a place across the entire federal
government
let's go live to our U.S correspondent
Mark Stone in Washington the FBI boss
adding his voice to concerns already
expressed here in the UK
yes and not just him the CIA boss and
other intelligence Chiefs at this annual
um Gathering where they for uh for the
American public are on television and
are asked about all sorts of global
threats as they see them and one word
came up again and again and again and it
was China Tick Tock if you like is the
tangible headline through which the
public can attempt to understand the
threat as the American intelligence
Community sees it from China and there
was an interesting exchange where they
described precisely how they believe
China is literally in the Chinese
Communist party is literally in the
palms of everyone's hands and the access
that they have to our data is
breathtaking so says the intelligence
Community but I was struck by by the
extent to which China as a threat really
seems to permeate everything here it
screamed from the the news channels uh
every single day the threat from China
whether it's spy balloons whether it's
Chinese companies buying up land in the
United States whether it is our um the
fact that we rely on everything that
China offers to such a huge degree now
it really feels like this all-important
relationship that between America and
the Chinese is in a very perilous and
dangerous state right now
in Washington thank you
well someone welcome news now for most
of us at least Council taxes will rise
for many next month with some of the
most deprived areas facing the biggest
hikes this postcode Lottery over the
cost of local Services raises
fundamental questions about fairness
during the cost of living crisis Tom
Cheshire has been finding out more
almost all of us have to pay council tax
but the amount varies massively
depending on where you live Hannah Lucy
and Zoe are in okem which under Rutland
Council has the highest rates in the
country
do you guys feel like you're getting
value for money from that that's true
no I think it's um it's reached a point
where we're seeing
development in the town but also an
actual reduction in the infrastructure
and in the facilities it's stripping
back it's just making an already
unaffordable situation harder yeah you
know you're already
um try not to turn your heating on as
much as possible to save those few extra
pennies people pay council tax based on
the type of property they live in
calculated all the way back in 1991 and
the value it was then
it's tough for people like Lucy Zoe and
Hannah in Rutland they live in an area
with the highest council tax in the
whole of the country and over 2 400
pounds Nottingham Lewis Dorset and
Wilden not far behind all in the top
pairs of tax
by comparison three of the lowest paying
places are in London if you live in a
bandee property in Westminster you're
only paying 883 pounds for the privilege
when we look at proportion of income
people in Mole Valley Council area are
paying over eight percent of their
income on council tax but at the other
end of the scale in Southwest London
Wandsworth people are paying just 2.1
percent
council tax is the definition of a
postcode Lottery houses here in
Wandsworth can cost millions of pounds
but people are spending a lower
proportion of their income than people
in poorer areas and there's plenty more
inconsistency across the system
back in okum and it also looks well to
do but Rutland Council says that masks
some deprived areas and argues they
receive much less funding from central
government per household than other
places there is a fundamental message
around fairness to 504 pounds compared
to 1019 pounds really simply isn't fair
over the coming weeks Sky News will be
looking at which councils are failing
and how that affects the services we all
depend on wherever we live Tom Cheshire
Sky News Oakland Rutland
a man has been arrested over footage
shot inside a police Cordon on the day
the body of Nicola bully was found
police in Lancashire said the 34 year
old man from kidderminster was arrested
on suspicion of malicious Communications
offenses and perverting the course of
Justice in connection with the
investigation to find was bully
police on merseyside have arrested three
people in connection with the murder of
L Edwards on Christmas Eve her 20 year
old man has been charged with possession
of a prohibited weapon and assisting an
offender while a 23 year old man and
woman were arrested on suspicion of
conspiracy to commit murder and both
have now been released on bail
the Met Office says some places could
see 40 centimeters or almost 16 inches
of snow between now and Friday lunchtime
an Amber warning is in place for heavy
snow causing significant disruption in
an area stretching from Stoke-on-Trent
to Durham it comes as the UK recorded
its coldest March temperature in more
than a decade
now it's been described as a game
changer a weight loss injection endorsed
by celebrities and available on the NHS
within months which works by making
patients feel Fuller for longer but
after largely unregulated use in the U.S
a former Health Minister has warned that
it shouldn't be used for those wanting
to look good on the beach a health
correspondent oh she's Joshi has more
it's something that I'm constantly
thinking about I'm I'm judged the minute
someone meets me Sarah has struggled
with her weight for her entire adult
life that's more than 20 years of diets
and Weight Management Programs nothing's
worked she hopes mugletide will this is
literally going to change everything
because what it's doing is changing the
physiological makeup of my body so it's
changing my hormones it's changing the
way that the signals are going to my
brain it's changing the way I'm going to
think around food for instance and then
the way that my body thinks around food
and that's going to make such a huge
impact on
just general life so it's different for
everyone also known as wegovi the drug
is a higher dose of a diabetes
medication ozympic it works by
suppressing the patient's appetite the
treatment has exploded in popularity in
the United States sparked by a viral
trend on social media
and endorsements from celebrities like
Elon Musk the drug is used as a reset
moment not as a lifestyle option this is
not a drug to be used for people who are
just trying to look good on the beach
this is a drug for people who are really
wrestling with obesity and need a break
from the pressures of fighting uh with
their with their appetites over the last
30 years
advantage of clinically obese people in
the UK has increased from around 15 to
just under 30 percent obesity is
estimated to cause about 30 000 deaths
in the UK each year
the drug will only be offered to
patients on specialist NHS Weight
Management Programs like the ones they
run here at St Thomas's Hospital there
are already serious supply issues with
some modular tide with private clinics
being accused of stockpiling the drug
following celebrity endorsements the
drug was first used in diabetes
treatment and now senior doctors have
told us they're worried because diabetes
patients are now at risk because of
access to the drug Sarah knows she might
not get some ugly tied until the end of
the year but after 20 years of battling
with his size she desperately hopes it
will be worth the wait oh she's Joshy
Sky leaves